we begin with the latest covid coverage
as the now dominant delta variant
spreads throughout the nation and cobit
19
case numbers continue to spike the plea
for more people to get vaccinate is
becoming more urgent
michael george reports from new york
in burbank california workers are
converting a floor of this hospital
back into a coveted 19 ward in a lot of
ways it's been like going backwards
nursing manager chris rice says only
about six weeks ago
the hospital held a celebration because
it had zero covid patients
but after the fourth of july which is
when all the family gatherings began to
happen and all of the
restrictions started to get lifted it
started to get bad again
over the past two weeks new cases in the
u.s are up more than 160 percent
driven by the highly contagious delta
variant the last two weeks have
actually been outpacing the sort of
worse
part of our prediction interval and are
quite concerning
unc epidemiology professor justin
lessler says his group's research models
project the current surge
could peak in october with death rates
tripling what they are now
even though he almost died in an orange
county california icu
brian parisi still says he's not certain
he would have been better off getting
the vaccine
i honestly don't know that i would have
personally
but i think it's a it's an individual
decision during the pandemic
this new york city couple decided to
postpone their wedding
in a weird way it kind of made me knows
real
because you know when you're staying
together in the house for
extra two years it just brought us
closer
now they're among the first to get
married in person at new york city's
marriage bureau
following the office's 16-month shutdown
michael george cbs news new york